[Music]
I'm Michelle Miller from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish today we're
talking breakfast it's known as the most
important meal of the day but we're
going Beyond traditional eggs and bacon
from tasty breakfast burritos in Alaska
yes that's a thing to Sweet and Savory
pancakes in Nashville we start with
brunch in Southern California where
Jamie wax met a chef who's growing his
own produce for a place called Poppy and
Seed
this is called a buzz bun okay so you
can eat the whole thing but it's gonna
overpower you just take a little piece
off of it Chef Michael Reed's Outdoor
Garden is full of unique ingredients put
it on your tongue you're going to start
getting a tingling sensation like pop
rocks wow that's that's it's kind of
crazy the 39 year old Chef calls this
Outdoor Oasis his playground and
delights and using its fresh results for
his dishes and it makes you salivate it
makes you hungry and makes you curious
like what did I just do happening here
yes
this is one of the craziest things I've
ever experienced the bright Greenhouse
setting and Courtyard of his Poppy and
Seed in Anaheim California is surrounded
by Lush herbs vegetables and edible
flowers what would you describe your
cooking as it's basically very seasonal
I've always loved Italian I love French
I love Asian food so we basically get to
hide and sneak certain ingredients and
to still be a california-based
restaurant but build a lot of umami
flavors by using fermentation and
different ingredients that you normally
wouldn't find in most dishes to boost
that flavor I like to say we give you
something that's familiar with a Twist a
Twist you can taste and dishes like
seared scallops with pork belly maitake
mushrooms a celery root puree and Beluga
lentils Beluga lentils are a fancy
lentil they have a little bit more
density and texture to it once you put
it all together it's a perfect little
bite the textures alone
are amazing but then the flavors all
start to meld in your mouth shrimp and
lobster risotto the colors again and the
freshness of all the herbs on this are
absolutely phenomenal finished with
mascarpone and Parmesan cheeses it's one
of my favorites to make here also on the
table crispy mushrooms with an egg yolk
topped with Parmesan cheese all right
I'm gonna break this perfect egg yolk
look at that oh is that perfect
hand-rolled three cheese tortellini and
brodo avocado toast with pickled chilies
and shallots on sourdough bread ricotta
filled squash blossoms with herbs and
truffle honey crispy cheesy and sweet
yep that's the Truffle hunting on top
raised in Oxnard California Reed credits
his parents for his green thumb garden
growing up you know we had blackberries
my mom would make ice cream we had peach
trees avocado trees you know artichokes
my mom was always growing stuff part of
the punishment was like if you did do
your chores or you got in trouble go to
your guardian pick weeds you know and
you're just like come on
now I really appreciate what they taught
me and you know understanding it it
takes a lot to grow a lot of food but
like many chefs cooking for a living
wasn't his first dream I was on a track
and field scholarship I was a long
distance Runner so I broke my foot had a
bone chip coach said I would never run
as fast as I would my freshman year I
was like you're right the Olympics are
gone kind of shatter that drink and so
when I switched motivation from being in
a business accounting in school to being
like I kind of had the plan B already
lined up being like you don't really
like School culinary school seems more
your speed I was always cooking for the
track team Reed would eventually land at
the prestigious Culinary Institute of
America went there did the two-year
program worked at the Modern in New York
fell in love with fine dining in there
so then it snowed and I promptly moved
back to California
it took two years of driving upstate and
then back to Manhattan and then one big
storm I was like before it snows again I
have to leave grilled meatballs bread
scallops mushroom butter lettuce after
skipping a couple of steps he became an
executive chef at 26 years old
you got that butter lettuce ready
by 28 he was burned out and had to
discover what not only fed his customers
but also fed his soul I like him I like
him I like him a little bit I love her
though she may like me but I love her
hey my friend so you guys ordered some
good things he and his wife Queenie
opened a popular La brunch spot called
Poppy and Rose with him as the chef and
her on the business side I respect him
when I go into the kitchen he Chef if I
tell him there's something that we can't
buy because we need to do X Y and Z or
we're falling short here or we've made
really good Revenue here I need for you
to look at that he trusts me to say okay
I understand and we work together on
building this dream that we're building
together so is this meringue
the power couple are continuing to grow
their dream together with this space
that blossomed during a pandemic I want
something unique on the plate the only
way to do it is to sometimes grow it
yourself and like the food they've grown
themselves Michael and Queenie Reed seem
to always be reaching toward the sun I
think it's essential for restaurants and
restaurant owners to stay positive and
give a safe warm inviting place for
people to come break bread have
memorable experiences share stories and
you know bring people together
up next a trip far off the beaten path
to a rugged part of Alaska where we
found a restaurant serving up much more
than meat and potatoes
[Music]
in one of the most remote regions of the
country sits a humble sounding joint
called the potato but don't let the name
fool you as Jeff glor found out this
eater relocated inside a national park
is serving up some Elevated Cuisine
inside on summer nights the potato might
look like any one of your favorite
neighborhood restaurants hungry diners
scooping up food at the camp Miss Corner
Hangouts
but step outside and you realize this
neighborhood is unlike any other in the
world
surrounded by America's largest national
park in America's largest state
the potato is a restaurant in McCarthy
Alaska that requires the ultimate
commitment to Travel and Adventure I
always I just had a hankering for
finding a nice wild place I grew up in
the city and I still appreciate it but I
wanted to be in the outdoors Ian Curie
is part of a small team behind the
potato a classically trained Chef who
once worked at some of the finest
restaurants in San Francisco he runs the
kitchen Rebecca Bard runs the front of
the house I was here for a trip I had
been doing archeology and I had heard
that they wanted somebody to come and
revamp the bar so I I came here to work
at the bar and never left and left my
degree what Bard and Yuri have created
here is nothing short of remarkable
they rely on only one food delivery a
week are only open four months of the
year and never know what the harsh
conditions that surround them might
bring next the services that people get
out here are at an unexpected level
compared to other parts that they've
traveled in the state yeah so like you
don't expect to get this quality I mean
no offense to McCarthy or anybody else
but you don't expect yeah no we hear
that all the time so you get a lot of
adventurous tourists out here so it
gives you the ability to go beyond just
doing Burgers when we do something like
a miso salad it's one of our best
sellers are you catering to a fine
dining
crowd or are you catering to
the backpacking crowd or is it the same
thing it's very casual we welcome
everyone but you can get Elevated
Cuisine here and you can get a burrito
here all day and the burrito is what has
always been the Staples it's what's paid
the bills not long after we arrived
giori showed us how the famed Potato
Head Burrito is assembled how did this
become the signature well it was
invented by the original owner of the
potato and it initially was a breakfast
burrito with egg potato chunks in it
salsa sour cream and jalapenos we took
it and we decided it might be a little
better if we put the fries in it and
once we tried that it was game over and
it's it's what a lot of Backpackers come
get first when they come out of the back
country here the process starts with a
generous handful of shredded cheese on
the tortilla well that moved to the oven
to warm up we moved to the eggs you guys
are really making me do the whole thing
here huh everything wow okay we threw
Carnitas and chorizo on the flat top now
you don't want to forget about yours
right no of course never so gently damn
it you want to tilt the pan and move the
eggs around you're just trying to get it
to recoat the bottom a little bit
gentle is not a word usually in my life
you ready for the fun part
flip it
how do you do that yeah well
hey that's not there you go now turn the
heat off and it'll finish cooking in the
warm pan
that was impressive actually thank you
then it was time for the part that puts
the potato in the Potato Head Burrito
hand cut curly fries why are your fries
so good you know I really don't know
love
well the fries cooked in peanut oil we
did one final check on our proteins
before beginning the assembly the eggs
go first the meat is second so now all
our fries oh that smells amazing well
our fries are dripping dry yeah put a
little salsa
yeah not too much but not too little
sour cream okay and next
about five to six little pickled
jalapenos
or eight to ten depending yeah
all that's missing were the curly fries
salted of course no more salt no more
salt which left us the task of rolling
this mother of all breakfast burritos
into a perfect cylinder
I almost I think kind of all right and
then now
fold the bottom because we want to keep
it contained again
no
um turn it 90 degrees you're fine it'll
all end up inside like this yep and then
I don't know this did you tear your I
tore it okay we'll get a new phone give
me a new one the second time mercifully
was the charm simple basic
from the heart
beautiful why be fancy when you can be
delicious Cheers Cheers
can I eat
oh
did you nail it
you nailed it no I didn't make it
amazing
to accompany the burrito there was an
Eclectic mix of other Potato menu
selections the miso salad with shave
brussels sprouts mixed greens a soft
boiled egg and crispy fried onions
salmon with Citrus aioli roasted beets
confit potatoes kale and Spruce tips on
top bangers and mash with homemade
sausage sauerkraut stone ground mustard
and pickled red onions mac and cheese
with brussels sprouts
and the sputnik's Supreme and original
potato dish featuring biscuits and gravy
sausage with eggs cheese and jalapenos
what they call both a gut bomb and The
Breakfast of Champions
this thing is dangerous a monster a
monster a monster of goodness yeah but
like that will fill your stomach and the
person sitting next to you yeah and when
they're not even eating I don't know how
people finish them but they do
should I try no well we'll be here
the potato is one of the most distinct
dishes we've ever experienced
led by a Duo that doesn't seem to belong
anywhere else
and I know if I had to run a kitchen
like this year round I probably wouldn't
be as happy of a person as I am I get I
get my Winters off to do other jobs or
relax or travel
and I think that we've both cultivated
that lifestyle being in a town where the
industry is seasonal it's tourist
so that works for us
Jamie wax is back with us but this time
he hits up a few major Metro areas
getting creative with their morning
menus
from traditional bacon
eggs and pancakes Breakfast in America
while tasty has lacked the creative
Focus chefs have given to lunch and
dinner
but over the past few years that has
changed in a major way giving customers
a diverse array of thoughtfully crafted
options is it fair to say that breakfast
is the new dinner well I would say you
still gotta eat dinner but what I like
about breakfast now and by breakfast I
mean sort of that weekday meal when I
get Talking brunch but you got much more
creative dishes you have much more
healthy dishes this is not the breakfast
we're used to though yeah it's a cliche
but you know breakfast is the most
important meal of the day chefs are now
realizing that and they want to apply
their sort of attention to detail their
creativity to this meal and I think the
customers are responding
acclaimed chefs from across the country
are bringing their A-game to the morning
meal this is probably the second most
ordered dish on the menu it is and many
single out one Chef as the pioneer of
the current Trend a lot of people credit
you for sort of starting this new
movement is that fair
I'll take it yeah squirrel is the tiny
bustling La restaurant that is the baby
of Chef Jessica koslow I remember when I
was opening squirrel a very prominent
Chef here in L.A it was like I will
never do breakfast and lunch there's no
margins in it there's no no alcohol
um it's a Young Person's game good luck
when did you know you had really started
something that was culture changing
maybe right when I opened the door
I felt at that moment so many people
responded to having a place that they
could have a unique experience in dining
but during the daytime at a price that
was more affordable you got Shack toes
working okay I need two all day from
popularizing her Twist on Avocado toast
to creating dishes like crispy rice
salad disco and flat tots an elevated
potato pancake koslo has created a
breakfast menu that is anything but
typical I think what's interesting about
squirrel is that they proved that a
breakfast can be a money maker you can
pack the house and you can also cook
really creatively you can come up with
dishes that are just as tempting and
invigorating and sort of eye-opening as
on a dinner menu cat is delicious okay
squirrel's influence is surprised even
koslo herself it is remarkable to see
that there's an idea here that other
chefs are starting to translate into
their own work foreign
that includes michelin-starred chefs
like Daniel Rose of Le cuckoo in New
York this one is
about three days and the famed fine
dining Maestro Jean George vongariston
plus to be healthy colorful
we're good John George now has breakfast
service in five of his restaurants do
you think this breakfast movement in
some ways is sort of pushed forward by
Young Chefs like
Jessica's young chefs are really
starting a new movement and I really
admire them for you know pushing forward
for me breakfast now become my favorite
meal of the day really yeah absolutely
could you imagine yourself 46 years ago
saying that no absolutely not Mason
Hereford surprised many by Landing the
number one spot on Bon appetit's list of
new American restaurants with his New
Orleans sandwich shop turkey and the
Wolf match on the side Hereford has also
gotten high marks for his newer
breakfast focused restaurant Molly's
rise and shine which he runs with his
fiancee Lauren agudo this is kind of our
piece of Americana breakfast sandwich
it's got sausage fried hash brown
American cheese grilled onions and then
ketchup this is sort of one of the
weirder dishes it's a deviled egg
tostada with a peanut salsa and refried
red bean pickled peppers onions cilantro
this smells unbelievable yeah that one's
I think that's one of my faves even so
if you're a fan of traditional morning
fare who finds all these new choices a
bit overwhelming Adam Rappaport says not
to worry there's still room for everyone
at the table there's always going to be
designers out there there's always going
to be the basic places that we all love
to go to to get our stack of pancakes or
fried eggs and bacon sometimes we just
want a greasy plate of eggs and bacon
yeah let's say you might have had a
drink or two the night before you're
just like I just need some hash browns
and bacon and eggs and I'm good
coming up a story hot off the presses or
should we say Fresh Off The Griddle
you're watching the dish
welcome back and could you please pass
the syrup we're joining CBS Sunday
morning's Maraca on a winding path of
pancakes from Michigan to Tennessee
for Kalamazoo Michigan's Michelle Bates
Phipps a pancake is simply a canvas the
real magic comes with what's added
banana walnut apple cinnamon my next
batch will be oatmeal raisin cookie
flavor
her latest creation
carrot cake pancakes
these are just baby cupcakes baby
carrots you can use regular carrots but
baby carrots are easier because you
don't have to peel them okay oh okay
because I'm all about easy Michelle is
someone who chooses her words carefully
did you always love carrots
a good question
I would have to say I have not always
been a fan of carrots and yet these
carrot cake pancakes want a blue ribbon
from the popular recipe website Just A
Pinch tell me
about the moment you found out that
you'd won
it was like a oh I want another award
that's great you don't sound all that
excited
foreign
someone who is excited by Michelle's
pancakes her husband Willie Phipps a
blind jazz musician
tell me about Michelle's pancakes
they're delicious
oh my God
go ahead
I'm making pancakes
in Kalamazoo
[Music]
Kalamazoo
first really American cookbook has um
hoe cakes in there which are basically
pancakes but they're made with corn
instead food historian Ken albala
managed to write a whole book about
pancakes the recipe is really
proliferate in the 19th century and it
becomes one of those quintessential
breakfast foods and something that's
really gonna you know give you a lot of
energy throughout the day
and you might need that energy to wait
in the line at Nashville's legendary
Pancake Pantry come this way
the pancakes sell like hotcakes
Dave Baldwin is the owner of this half
century-old institution what's the
biggest mistake people make when they
make pancakes over beating the batter
there should be lumps in it when it's
still just a liquid batter is that right
yeah lightly mix it let it sit a minute
the sheer variety of Pancakes here keeps
this place packed seven days a week
Southwest cornmeal pancakes
Caribbean pancakes whoa raspberry
Delight wow
that's a big bite son
but the bite I'd been craving was from
Michelle's carrot cake pancake
let's try some
it tastes like carrot cake
it's great isn't it
this calls for a toast who said
breakfast can't be a special occasion
[Music]
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Michelle
Miller we'll see you next time for
another helping of the dish
[Music]